being in community where you're hearing
the same things over and over getting
your mind right getting your psychology
right and reinforcing the strategy is
critical
for cutting through the noise standing
out on youtube and experiencing massive
success so this framework is the rapid
skill development framework on how to
quickly learn and master the necessary
skills for growing to a hundred thousand
subscribers and beyond
hey welcome to the think media podcast
my name is heather torres and i am your
host here on this show where we help you
grow your influence on youtube and then
turn that influence into a high impact
and a high profit online business now
when it comes to strategy around youtube
that's what most experts are teaching
and here at think media we love to go a
lot deeper we understand that in order
to be successful on youtube to grow a
channel to over a hundred thousand
subscribers and really make a big impact
there's so much more that goes into that
so on today's episode we wanted to dive
in deeper into one of the trainings that
sean recently just did now this is a
portion of that training that i thought
would be really valuable for you here on
the show and sean is going to give some
context around one of our offers that we
have here at think media and if you'd
like to go deeper in knowing more about
what we do here when it comes to
understanding how to do youtube right
and if you would like a free class you
go to
learnvideo2022.com actually today's
episode
is brought to you by learnvideo2022.com
and that's where we have our free class
where you can test drive video ranking
academy uh and there's so much more you
can learn over there so if you'd like to
go deeper after this training and you
like what we're teaching here definitely
check that out well let's jump into
today's episode and i'll catch you right
after
[Music]
the rapid skill development framework
and so you can use this to learn and
master the necessary skills
for growing to a hundred thousand
subscribers and beyond
you know one of the truths about today's
world
is that the only way to win is to learn
faster than anyone else
we are in this accelerated information
age where
they've even said this i learned this
i'm reading a book called life force by
tony robbins it's all about medical
breakthroughs and it said that that even
in medicine there's a half-life that 18
months after a doctor graduates
from university there's a half-life to
their knowledge
so about like a year and a half after
graduating their knowledge is 50
outdated and then it just half-lifes
down so you go 10 years past them
getting out of university
and if they're not staying current with
their knowledge they're falling behind
and i know that feels like a lot of
pressure but what it just tells us is
that we have to develop the ability to
rapidly continually develop skills
and really ask ourselves the question
what are the skills that i need to
survive and thrive in the new economy
we have to become if we want to to
stay ahead and not just get ahead
we have to continuously learn i've heard
it said that
lifelong leaders
are lifelong learners
now let me know in the comments if you
would consider yourself a leader
yes or no
but whether you do or not let me tell
you today that you you need to start
considering yourself a leader
literally
think about social media
an only way to succeed on social media
and youtube is to have
followers
and the only way to have followers
is if
you're
a leader because a leader without
followers is not a leader and in a
social media account or a youtube
channel without subscribers will not be
successful
and so ultimately it's not that you have
to be a leader in the traditional sense
like a religious leader or political
leader
but you want to be a leader in your
industry you want to be a leader as a
comedian you want to be a leader even as
a vlogger you want to be a leader and so
lifelong leaders though are lifelong
learners in order if you're
currently blessed to have anybody
following you
the only way to be having people
continually follow you watch is you
can't stop growing
because if you stop growing then those
following you by the way they'll either
stop or they'll leave
so so this i know it feels like a lot of
pressure but that's the responsibility
of being a leader and it comes down to
just this commitment
i just got to keep going
because that means that i i only need to
be a few steps ahead today to start my
youtube channel when i started back in
2000 and
you know 10 uploaded my first video i
started teaching i made a video in my
car
talking about how to build a video
editing pc i know like 10 times more now
but i knew
enough then to start
and people who knew nothing about
building computers were like man this is
very helpful so i just was sharing my
answers for where i was at but watch the
only way i could be where i am today is
if i didn't stop growing it was a
commitment to growth it was a commitment
to development so here's the question
then
how do i rapidly develop the skills
necessary
for growing on youtube to 100 000
subscribers and beyond
and we've created this framework that is
the rapid skill development framework
and it starts at the tip with the
strategy with strategy
so so the tip of the spear if you will
is strategy what does that mean it means
to win on youtube you got to have the
right system you got to have the right
tactics you got to have the right plan
maybe you've looked up a video how do i
get views on youtube and someone shared
a tip or a couple tips of how to do it
you need that
you gotta have the right strategy
like a failing strategy will mean that
you ultimately fail
so what is your battle plan for winning
on youtube what are the tactics and by
the way there's a difference between
tactics and strategy
a tactic is like one thing like write a
good title but you're never going to win
on youtube by just writing a good title
you need a cohesive strategy
and so what we've learned though
is that strategy is the tip of the spear
you're not going to cut through the
noise if your strategy isn't solid but
strategy is only one piece
of the puzzle the second thing you need
is psychology
and and here's
this one's so much more important
because information alone is not enough
you don't need me to convince you of
that because we literally live in the
age where information is at our
fingertips
on the other side of the philosopher
google we can ask any question and get
the answer
information is becoming more and more
common
and so
the
you maybe have heard that knowledge is
power or information is power that's not
true
applied
knowledge is power
so you don't just need the strategy
you actually need the psychology what
does that mean it means the mindset and
the will and the determination and the
discipline to execute on the strategy
the reason i know this right is is that
if it really comes down to it
if we were to ask ourselves right
do we know how to be healthy
do we really need a new book on it now i
buy new books on it
but if you really boil it down
it would be eat healthy and exercise you
know what i mean like if
it doesn't matter if it looks pretty or
not when i when i exercise it does not
look pretty when i run i'm like i'm like
a hunch kind of hunched over i'm 6'1
kind of lanky like it doesn't look great
but i'm burning calories
and and it's good to get out and move
but
if you're like me you still might be
watching that infomercial and you're
like oh wow there's a little device for
just three payments of 29.99 and i can
just connect these electrodes to my abs
and have six pack abs in a couple months
it's not real that's not not true the
the thing is it's having a strategy but
you actually have to apply it what is
that that's the psychology piece
so the psychology piece this is remember
the rapid skill development and this is
talking about this is just stuff that a
lot of people wouldn't really share with
you because i even watching this you
might be like why don't you teach about
thumbnails why can't you just tell me
the secrets of the algorithm and talk
about analytics we cover all that
like we teach all this that stuff but
friend
is that really the most important thing
or is actually the most important thing
is you getting motivated and getting off
the couch and actually punching fear in
the face and pressing record
is the is it is the information the
thing you're lacking or is it actually
the mindset and the courage to not be
afraid of what other people think and
actually share your voice powerfully
online
is is is it really the strategy and the
tips is that your biggest challenge or
is it the
unbreakable will and confidence to crash
through quitting points so the
psychology piece is like having a growth
mindset
the belief that you control your own
ability and can learn and improve
that's the key to success right yes hard
work and effort and persistence are
important but it's not as important as
having an underlying belief that you are
in control of your own destiny
and i've personally learned that i've
needed to do a lot of mindset work
a lot of belief work
so that i could get myself to take
action
on the strategy and the information i
have
i was just like doing my morning routine
today and i was looking at my bookshelf
and i was looking at all the books i
haven't read yet
the information is potential power but i
need to not just read the book i got to
apply the book psychology right actually
putting it into action so confidence
healthy self-esteem a resilient mindset
that will beat adversity a strong
mindset will increase your drive strong
psychology and mental toughness pushes
you towards your goals it shifts you
into possibility thinking and it shifts
your perspective on things a disciplined
mindset is what's needed to cut through
the distractions of modern culture you
do not need endless information you need
the confidence to take massive continued
action
psychology
psychology but that is not the only
piece
yes we need solid strategy
we need a plan we need to understand how
youtube works
yeah we also need
a strong mindset and strong psychology
but there's another piece and that's
community
that's community
so community
is this piece that we have now studied
and this isn't just apply to youtube
this applies to business this applies to
like life it applies to like staying
married what's so fascinating
is who you're around really matters
the community around you really matters
like they discover charles tremendous
jones said it this way you're going to
be the same person
in five years as you are today except
for the people you meet and the books
you
read that's how he put it
you're going to be exactly the same
place you are today in five years
except for like basically the
information you learn
but also the people you're around
it's just true walk with the wise become
wise
bad company corrupts good character
the fastest way to change yourself is to
hang out with people who are already
where you want to be
the more most powerful thing i've
learned out of strategy and psychology
but how to hack those two things is
community
and i've learned that getting around
people in some cases well sean i don't
know how do i get around people but i've
learned the way i do it listening to
people's podcasts reading people's books
attending events
being in a community where the
impossible becomes possible where the
impossible is logical for some people
around you they might only see defeat
and cynicism and it might feel like you
look around and all you see is people
struggling we look around and all we see
is people succeeding
it's not because we're disconnected from
the true hardships in the world it's
just when you hang out with people who
have a growth mindset who see
possibilities who overcome challenges
who are not delusional who just
acknowledge challenges and see every
challenge as an opportunity that has a
seed in it for for greater growth for
that every problem
is an opportunity that's entrepreneur
thinking because you need problems to
solve
entrepreneurs solve problems for a
profit but do you are you around a
community that is
encouraging you with that and giving you
those types of
mindset growth
and and and it's kind of that thing
where we talk about this when it comes
to community there's a lot of stuff
that's actually more caught than it is
taught
it's one thing to just read words on a
page but this is why i love being
immersed and around somebody where stuff
just kind of rubs off on you where
courage just kind of rubs off on you
we're seeing possibilities just kind of
rubs off on you what you listen to
matters what you read matters what you
see matters who you hang out with
matters
and investing in that this has been what
i've learned now watch
i've learned that strategy
is about 20 of the equation
now the tip of the spear matters
sharpening the tip of that arrow is
critical to cut through the noise and
succeed on youtube but it's only about
20 of the success
people over emphasize how important it
is
like if your strategy is not right
then you will stay stuck however
think about
the unopened course material on your
computer or on the cloud think about the
unread book on yourself right
think about the the unapplied note you
wrote in your journal
that's why that's why when you really
just think about it you go okay like i
needed to know the thing to do but the
kind of more important thing is that i
actually do it which is why psychology
is about 40 of success
more important is actually applying what
you know to do and therefore having that
mindset having that uh having having the
will and the mental toughness to
continually apply it because the other
thing is is that strategy is never
instantaneous
so so you have to have the mental
toughness to know oh i tried once and it
didn't work well no kidding you and
everybody else well i uploaded one of my
favorite things that happens when it
comes to us doing channel reviews and
doing youtube coaching is people ask
questions we're open to every question
as people you know share what they're
struggling with in the in the chat and
in the comments we're open to hearing
and listening and we have big hearts of
love and empathy
but one of my favorite things people
will say to me is like hey sean
i've been trying this youtube thing and
it's just not working
that is my favorite invitation to click
through and look at their channel
sean i just don't get it i tried your
tips and they're just not working
really sir okay let me check let me
click through and look at your channel
and here's what i see on the channel
i see no cover art
their avatar is a d the letter d it's no
they didn't upload an avatar picture the
youtube logo
i see that there's six videos on the
channel one was 12 months ago the next
one was 10 months ago they uploaded one
three months ago and none of them have
thumbnails one's a weird gaming play
through then one is them sharing their
tips on success and then their newest
video is like a youtube short of their
dog playing in the snow
sean
it's just not working bro you're just
not working it
like you can't you could say it's just
not first of all you haven't even
applied the information
second of all you haven't even been
consistent applying the information you
uploaded six videos in the last 12
months six different topics six
different formats and you're not even
doing half the best practices
applying the actual knowledge and i
understand that that takes psychology
and that's why actually doing it is
about 40 percent of success
but the other 40 is that community piece
it's that community piece because i've
actually learned personally maybe you're
different that i've learned personally i
can't succeed alone i have to lock arms
and get other people around me you got
to know that something kinetic happens
when i'm around heather taurus i dream
bigger she helps me reframe like it may
seem like i'm always in a positive state
of mind maybe not sometimes you're like
you're kind of sometimes a little bit
saucy sean but like
like you you know you'd be surprised i
need omar and mel and heather who speak
life into me and hope into me when i'm
exhausted and when when i'm not seeing
uh you know tired eyes rarely see a
bright future and there are definitely
moments where i start getting super
cynical and i'm seeing a negative future
not a positive future community you need
people in your circle
but more than that like it's like when
my friend uh when sometimes i'm feeling
down i turn on my friend peter voog who
made a mixtape and i start getting in
the wrong right mindset when i'm feeling
down i i turn on uh you know maybe a
sermon from my pastor jaben chavez and i
start getting in the right minds that's
community
i got people in my world
that can actually keep me on track you
might be fine alone i'm not
you might be fine by yourself i'm not
i need community
and i i would you could go to the back
of my book youtube secrets read the
acknowledgements and see the people
listed there who are instrumental in my
success some of peop some of them have
never met
it's because i've bought their courses
i've bought their books i listened to
their podcast that's my community
they're helping me get my strategy right
and my psychology right and sometimes
see we get accused sean you've said this
before
sean why not change something new i'm
not already seeing this video on think
media i can't believe you guys are
repeating yourself on think media well
we need to keep repeating ourselves sir
because you're not doing it
oh yeah you already posted this video
well how about you actually post a video
how about that oh i heard you post this
in another video why don't you actually
because i've learned this that
repetition is the father of learning and
the mother of mastery
so that actually being in community
where you're hearing the same things
over and over getting your mind right
getting your psycho
psychology right and reinforcing the
strategy is critical
for cutting through the noise standing
out on youtube and experiencing massive
success
so this framework is the rapid
development skill development framework
on how to quickly learn and master the
necessary skills for growing to 100 000
subscribers and beyond
you got to get your psychology right you
got to get your strategy right you got
to get your community right and notice
that community and psychology are almost
like the foundation that everything's
built on and strategy is the tip of the
spear
every piece matters they're weighted
differently though
but when every piece is intact
you're going to experience incredible
success and listen if you only if you
have like kind of weak psychology like
you're like i'm not very confident i
need a lot of help building my
confidence but you have the right people
around you or you're in the right
community and again that might be a
facebook community that might be uh it's
oftentimes multiple things it could be
local community in your local city but
it's also online communities that you're
a part of it's it's right now i mean
you're a part of even if you are never
part of any of our uh courses or
programs and you never join anything i'm
super grateful you're here in the chat
right now on one of our facebook pages
honor you i mean this is as much as we
can do a community that's free
our deepest level of community is in our
private facebook group on video ranking
academy and then on top of that it's the
strategy
and even if you have a 12 good strategy
your psychology is only 22 but you have
a strong community
then you
you add those together and you're still
gonna get momentum if you can max these
out i got the best strategy i'm getting
my confidence right my mindset right my
growth mindset right i'm
intentionally by the way it's a key word
being intentional about this stuff
i'm intentionally pursuing
world-class strategy the best in the
world
getting my mind right and building my
mental toughness and confidence
and getting around a community and this
is a journey i've been working on this
for the last 10 years and i work on this
rest of my life
but these are the pieces to rapid skill
development and and as we've learned
these
as i think media we've discovered these
we asked ourselves
you know how uh
this being true how could we create
a
community
where we could do our best at offering
people all of these elements
and that ultimately is what our special
offer is all about
it's about
the fact that you've got the strategy
inside of the course if it's only 20
it's critical i believe it's the best
course you'll ever take on youtube
but you also have one of the things we
created is called our camera confidence
course
and heather and i
researched and studied science-backed
psychological and confidence building
truths
that are not just things like makeup
background what clothes to wear how to
look right on camera raise the camera up
a little bit it's slimming you know like
some different things all the practical
things but also the mindset stuff
but then also the fact that we realized
we needed to create a community
where we could actually realize iron
sharpens iron and we do that in a
private facebook group and then more
than that and again again you might say
aha i see what you did there sean
it leads perfectly into
the fact that you have a solution for
that well it should because i didn't
just make this up like this is based on
research and personal development adult
learning theory that you need the
strategy you need the psychology and you
need the community so we said how do we
actually create that to give all of our
students the best possible chance of
success
can we do it for you we can't
it's on you
ultimately you've got to watch the
videos you've got to stay committed to
taking notes you've got to do the
workbook you've actually got to be
engaged in the facebook group you've got
to do all the stuff
but i know of nothing else like it that
gives you all the elements
problem is
a lot of people give you the strategy
but it's only 20
there is some good mindset training out
there but are they giving you enough of
a community to continually build the
mindset and is there even a community
you're like oh they promised a private
facebook group but it's completely dead
and there's no one in there and i don't
even blame the people that are letting
you down in those areas
because a lot of times they just haven't
actually built up a business model
that's that committed to customer
success so they haven't hired a faculty
and a team to support it there's no way
i could do there's no way i could
deliver all this to you
i can't
but sean and heather and omar and chris
and andy and victoria and mel and isaiah
and caleb and sam they can
and nolan
and steph
and kyle that's the think media team
the mission we're on we're so serious
about that we wanted to make sure all
the pillars were in place
to give you a place where you can
quickly learn and master the necessary
skills to grow into 100 000 subscribers
and beyond on youtube
and i hear me as well and if if if this
offer this learn video 20 if this offer
is not right for you well then don't do
it
like just find these pieces somewhere
because this remains true regardless you
got to get the strategy right get your
mindset right and get plugged into a
community i am completely
i'm excited that we might not be the
right community for for you
but i want you to win regardless so you
need to find a community somewhere
and you need to intentionally build up
your mental toughness somewhere
and you need to pick up i'm this isn't
even the only methodology for youtube
there's a lot of cool people out there i
get i speak at all the youtube events
like they're all my friends there's
different approaches all i know is that
we have the most consistent success with
our students because it's the most
practical youtube framework that i know
about
sure there's the unicorn mr b strategy
but it's a lot it's a lot rarer for
people to succeed kind of going that
viral
approach to things as opposed to brick
by brick intent based content that we
ultimately teach inside of era and so i
hope this serves you and what i want you
to do is think about and now rate
yourself how are these areas in your
life
the application item is do you have
confidence that you have the best
youtube strategies and information to
execute on if not you got to go get it
rate yourself in psychology like do you
feel like your confidence your mental
toughness your drive your ability to
crash through quitting points your
possibility thinking that you always you
spend almost no time in negative
thinking and you quickly bounce back
when you get down that's called
resilience how quickly do you recover
from kind of being knocked down or a bad
day how many good days in a row can you
connect and how many bad days can you
eliminate that bad days it's not it's no
longer you don't even have a bad day a
bad day is unacceptable it's a bad
moments just because of mental toughness
resilience bounced back because that
sucks this is hard
but it doesn't do me any good to wallow
in anxiety or worry i'm going to bounce
back from this it's a mental toughness
thing and then community do you have the
right people around you friend get these
pieces in place because there's there's
5x growth happening in the crater
economy over the next nine months and
this is going to be necessary because
the only way to win is to learn faster
than anybody else
and so you need to be quickly learning
and mastering the necessary skills for
crushing it on youtube
well i hope that that piece of that
training brought you value and if you're
not already subscribed here on the think
media podcast channel make sure you
subscribe because that's where we do
free trainings like this all the time
this was just a part of one of our
recent trainings and you can go deeper
at learn video 2022 now if you've not
already rated and reviewed the podcast i
want to encourage you to do that it's
one of my favorite things to do here on
the show where we get to read your
reviews of this show and when you do
that over on apple podcast it really
helps us to be able to reach more people
people get to check out the show and see
what people are saying about it before
they commit to 20 minutes 30 minutes 45
minutes of our episode so i want to
shout out tony jeffers today thank you
for leaving a review tony says full of
great information the information here
is so detailed and insightful for those
that are creating videos online or
producing content of any kind so
inspiring and motivating as well as
practical and easy to implement thank
you so much tony for leaving that review
it means the world to me to see all of
the reviews every single week coming in
from around the world and if you have
not left a
comment on youtube we also love to see
our youtube family as well so make sure
you leave a comment let me know where
you're watching from and how long you've
been a part of our think media family
well thank you so much for being a part
of what we're doing here at think media
we hope that you enjoy episodes like
this we have so many great episodes
coming up so you want to make sure
you're locked in here on the think media
podcast thanks for listening and we'll
catch you in the next episode bye
[Music]
you